today we're gonna be trying a really
delicious ice-cream treat called taiyaki
and I brought some friends
hi I'm Superman Emily here and we're
gonna get on the road and see what this
thing is like
taiyaki is a Japanese sweet treat that
looks like a type of fish called the sea
bream it usually consists of pancake or
waffle batter and is filled with red
bean paste in recent years some versions
have evolved to include delicious
delicious ice cream the treat has been
enjoyed by the people of Japan for over
a century so we had to try it - you sold
me ice cream is your favorite dessert
could you say that again I feel like I
was doing this to my face while you're
dying I like eclairs too but I guess
isn't that check out the ice cream
eclairs or not I know they're like the
ones that are in the freezer
she's talking about the chocolate eclair
ice cream bar okay so yes ice cream yep
I like ice cream what we're gonna eat
today is called taiyaki do you know what
that is no I just said because I don't
know what it is how's my driving it's
okay
given that hey it's ice cream time I'm
so excited I can't wait
it's so beautiful did you expect it to
be fish no this is so cool I don't know
if you can see it but it's like this
little fish shaped cookie and inside
they stuffed it with Nutella I got this
Bay and black sesame okay so I got the
same flavors Emily because I'm basic but
whatever it tastes good don't judge me
I got Liu Bei and I got red bean which
is kind of the classic Thai Aki filling
one God that is so good
why is it all food delivered to us
delightful animal-shaped package ROI by
weight room it's like sweet and a little
savory yeah but like very very subtle
red bean is kind of sweet it's not too
sweet I really like these flavors
because they're not overwhelming oh my
god waffle get this thing this thing my
[ __ ] I think we hated the wrong way
because I saw everybody else eating it
with a spoon I felt like I was stepping
in my face so I could get to the fish
part yeah I just wanted that sweet that
sweet fish meat I you know I think maybe
a waffle cone provides a little more
structure but it doesn't provide as much
fun as the fish cone
does it's like having a soft taco versus
a hard talkin oh my god everybody knows
a soft taco a soft taco always Trump's a
hard time right they weren't so rich
they were like very nice flavors that
all blended together really yeah I just
sort of like kind of where we requite
though I guess you know if this is
something you can get in your town I
definitely recommend getting you guys
doing anything fun this weekend
you